bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur la
france alors un essai clinique européen
pour tenter de trouver un traitement
efficace contre le port d'aden a été
lancée l'hôpital bichat fait partie des
cinq établissements français qui
participent à cet essai où est-ce qu'on
en lait et en quoi consiste cet essai
clinique
je pense que cet essai remet la balle au
centre
évite de dépassionner le toute cette
discussion qu'il a eue au tour de lit
drogue ce délit d' roxy chloroquine qui
n'était pas saine parce que il faut pas
penser que d'un côté il ya les
scientifiques qui il faut absolument
démontrer les choses pour pouvoir les
utiliser et que de l'autre côté il y a
des cliniciens des gens de coeur et qui
sont prêts à donner n'importe quoi leurs
patients pour qu'ils puissent en
bénéficier
la vérité c'est que la démarche
scientifique a pour intérêt de faire
bénéficier les patients des médicaments
des médicaments les plus efficaces et
les médicaments pour lequel on a prouvé
que ça a un intérêt de le donner que le
rapport bénéfice risque favorable aux
patients donc cet essai va comparer cinq
bras quatre molécules différentes dont
l'hydroxyte les rockin chloroquine et ça
va nous permettre d'avoir une preuve
scientifique rapidement de l'efficacité
d'une des options d'une des quatre
options qui sont testés actuellement
combien de temps il va durer ce test est
à titre personnel quel est votre avis
sur la chloroquine la ministre de la
santé a fait savoir que le traitement ne
pourraient être administrés aux cas les
plus graves après décision est médicale
collégiale alors quelqu'un vaccin ou un
traitement final contre le coc u19 se
fait toujours attendre
le mac sans ça va mettre un certain
temps à être développées et testées donc
aujourd'hui il faudrait il faut imaginer
que nous notre perspective de bénéficier
d'un traitement dé montrer efficace bien
toléré avec un rapport risque/bénéfice
favorable pour pouvoir le donner aux
patients les plus graves pour commencer
il est évident que ce protocole répond à
cet impératif et nous aurons une réponse
je pense très rapide
au bout de quelques semaines parce que
ce sont des protocoles très pragmatique
qui vise à faire d analyse intermédiaire
et dès que nous aurons un bras qui
montre son efficacité
on pourra dire que les patients pourront
bénéficier de ce traitement dont c'est
une question probablement de quelques
semaines aux makes au maximum est de
toute façon les patients qui
rentreraient dans ce protocole vont
bénéficier déjà de ces molécules faut
pas oublier qu'un protocole c'est aussi
l'option de bénéficier de ces
médicaments
les français sont en confinement depuis
plus d'une semaine le gouvernement on
l'annonçait plus de 22000 cap 2000 mort
est liée à l'épidémie également où
est-ce qu'on donnait au niveau du pic de
l'épidémie est ce qu'on l'a atteint ou
est ce qu'elle va se prononcer dans les
prochaines semaines c'est très difficile
de faire un pronostic mais moi je pense
que ça va continuer à monter encore nous
allons voir encore nombre de cas qui va
augmenter après c'est une question de
vitesse d'augmentation
malheureusement nous allons voir aussi
augmenter le nombre de personnes qui
présentent une forme grave qui nécessite
une hospitalisation et le nombre de
personnes avec une forme vraiment sévère
grave qui rompt réanimation et nous
allons continuer encore malheureusement
avoir des personnes qui vont décéder
c'est c'est douloureux d'où l'importance
de renforcer et d'être respectueux des
règles de confinement c'est vraiment
important que la population que tous nos
concitoyens prennent conscience que
c'est ce sacrifice parce que c'est
vraiment un sacrifice chacun d'entre
nous le vix est essentiel pour protéger
notre famille pour protéger nos proches
pour nos protégés nous mêmes et pour
protéger comme ça toute la société
alors on imagine que la fatigue au sein
du personnel soignant justement comment
est l'état de vos troupes les français
continuent d'applaudir à 20 heures le
personnel médical qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque alors nous sommes très mobilisés
je dois insister sur l'importance de
l'engagement la solidarité la
disponibilité de nos équipes
c'est quelque chose que nous n'avions
jamais connu
avant de façon très transversal tous les
personnels de tous les services sont
volontaires pour venir aider dans les
secteurs où nous prenons actuellement
les patients covit plus
ceci nous a permis de réorganiser
l'hôpital et de prévoir un nombre
suffisant de lits en médecine en
réanimation pour prendre ces patients
parfois avec des équipes qui depuis
plusieurs années était dans d'autres
secteurs de soins
nous avons fermé parce qu'on les a
considérés moins prioritaires dans le
contexte actuel il est indispensable que
chacun comprenne que nous soignons et
moi je le dis d'autant plus que je
rencontre au quotidien les équipes aux
urgences on réanimation en gériatrie aux
maladies infectieuses ont médecine qui
sont directement contact de ces patients
qu elles savent qu'elles prennent des
risques mais qui ce sont des risques qui
sont mesurées et nous donnons les moyens
de pouvoir protéger notre personnel ça
n'empêche qu'il y à une prise de risque
et qu'il faut rester en permanence très
concentré cette capacité à se protéger
le personnel dépend aussi de son niveau
d'épuisement professionnel
dernière question rapidement rdc
casalino justement où est-ce qu'on en
est au niveau du ravitaillement des
masques
est ce qu'aujourd'hui votre hôpital est
paré niveau protection la question des
lits de réanimation également fait son
apparition ou est-ce qu'on en ait pour
votre hôpital
actuellement nous avons le matériel en
nombre pour assurer les soins
il y à un effort immense logistique qui
est fait pour garantir
l'approvisionnement bien sûr mais les
équipes au quotidien dispose de ce
matériel il y à des choix stratégiques
qui peuvent être faits dans des secteurs
plus à risque ou des secteurs moins un
risque mais il est évident que la
protection de personnel est garanti
c'est notre priorité
et pour ce qui est des lits de
réanimation tous les jours
nous augmentons notre capacité en lits
de réanimation
notre hôpital par exemple à augmenter sa
capacité de lits de réanimation
pratiquement nous sommes sont en train
de la x 2
merci beaucoup et figues et tribunaux
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chef des urgences
de l'hôpital bichat à paris